former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg is expected to enter the
presidential race yeah yeah Republicans
are pointing out Americans don't want a
billionaire from New York City
it wants a guy who claims he's a
billionaire from New York City that's
what they want I'll be hilarious
you were probably on his first day he
would release his tax returns right
because he actually has billions and
billions and Trump has $800 else is
going on senator Kamala Harris is
proposing lengthening the school day to
6 p.m.
yeah yeah when asked why Harris said I
hate kids
[Applause]
well they can't vote yeah why would you
propose something so unpopular I don't
think I think yeah it's not what it
seems
yeah not what it seems yeah do you think
we made after school programs yeah
exactly yeah exactly do you think we
twisted it a little bit just to get a
cheap shot what I'll tell you later hey
in a I acted like I just remembered
something but there's a card
okay we know they know no I just I don't
know why the hell I went yeah well
anyway yeah oh yeah here this yeah I
just bought something in a new interview
that just came out Jamie Lee Curtis said
that she wants free based cocaine with
her dad actor Tony Curtis in it in his
defense it was bring your daughter to
work day
[Applause]
that's a fine reaction to a very creepy
story